another thing that people talk about
that women care about is penis size does
penis size matter for women in sexual
selection
well um there's controversy about that
in the evolutionary psychology community
well is there papers on penis size i
wouldn't say
uh scientific paper so speculations um
about
in nature or in science yeah yeah no
nothing nothing that i've seen there
um
you know i i think that there's
individual variability um so uh this is
something that comes up again you know
when i ask women in the class my classes
you know what do women want some will
say you know a large penis
but i think there's variability um in in
that preference and it also might depend
in part on the variability in
the woman's anatomy
so
um do you think there's something
fundamental in terms of evolutionary
psychology in terms of evolution or is
this a quirk of culture that's current
that's maybe somehow connected to
pornography or something like that yeah
my my guess is it's it's something
that's uh
perhaps a quirk of culture or or
something that is
evolutionarily recent
um but um but but i don't know i mean
it's it's a topic that hasn't been
explored much i've never done work on it
and well somebody should do a phd
sort of some archaeologist should do a
phd on the history of
human civilization
and its
evaluation of penis size and and the
correlation of penis size to the value
of the male